[Inaudible] guardians
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or Trump blue card.
And welcome Scandinavia.
[Inaudible] you have your.
You've had your own problems with, with the Russian state?
Yeah,
I was a reporter arriving in Moscow in Russia in 2007 with my
wife and my two brothers, small cute kids.
And within about three or four months, uh,
I was writing articles that just the manager saw on the video, Mr. Putin,
uh, um, we, we sort of found ourselves in a kind of rather bad spy,
thriller novel, and I had, um,
guys wearing cheap leather jackets,
sort of following me around the kind of icy streets of Moscow. Um,
and whenever I called London and for example,
made a joke about the Russian president, I would get kind of
underline would be mysteriously cuts, uh, for if someone was listening in,
I think that was fairly routine,
but what was kind of a bit dark and a bit funny and a bit terrible. It was,
we had a series of break-ins
in the apartment where I was living with my wife and kids,
and I went to go and see the, the British embassy in Moscow. And I said like,
you know, what, what the hell is going on? And they said, well,
I'm afraid your apartment is now bugged. Yeah. Uh, and, um,
they wanted you to know, instead of, you know, showing off almost, and I said,
is there anything we can do about it? And they said, no. Um, and I said,
is the video? And they said, yes. Uh, and it turned out, we had,
we had kind of total surveillance in our apartment, which is fairly usual.
And one of the reasons we knew this is on one occasion,
we're on holiday in Berlin. Um,
and we came back and the KGB stroke FSB had left us a little present
by the side of the bed, which I shared with my wife. Um,
and it was a sex manual in Russian, um,
together with all the kind of middle-class novels in English that I read,
someone had left a little presence, uh, and, um,
they bookmarked it, they put a bookmark in.
So I thought this is the strangest moment of my life.
And I turned over to page 127. Um,
and it was a page on orgasms. Uh, and I thought,
what message is the KGB trying to tell me and my wife, is it,
is there a technical issue perhaps, or, um, no,
the frequency or w w what is it, what was the tips?
[Inaudible].
The secret? The thing is, you know,
w when I came to sort of write the story of Donald from Russia,
it is this famous incident with Trump in 2013,
when he came in for the miss universe, beauty pageant, lots of beautiful women,
um, and this famous dossier by this British spy,
Christopher Steele says that that maybe Trump didn't go to
bed early with it, Swedish crime novel, that,
that maybe something else happened. Um, you know,
did Donald Trump behave badly and Moscow? We don't know.
Trump knows Putin knows Russian spiders. No,
but would their video everything he did? Of course they would.
Of course they would. So what they do.
Um, before, before we talk about today,
let's talk about 1987, uh, because this is, uh,
significant in your book. Uh, Trump goes to Moscow for the first time. Why,
why is that?
He's a kind of a young, famous property tycoon from New York,
and he's invited by the Soviet government to go to communists Moscow.
They pay all his expenses.
The Soviet ambassador goes to see him in Trump tower and says, you know, I have,
I have admired you, Mr. Trump, please come to Russia. Um,
and he, he goes there, um, to talk about building a hotel, which,
which never happens. And I think what's kind of interesting is, you know,
I've spoken to former KGB people who say this was a kind of
classic, it's called a kind of cultivation exercise.
You get to know someone, you give them a good time. And,
um,
what we also know from history is the KGB during this period was very keen to
kind of recruit more American contacts. Um, and so,
you know what precisely happened. We don't know,
but it looks to me what my sources say was,
this is a cultivation attempt 30 years ago of Donald Trump. And one more fact,
which is kind of extraordinary two months after this Moscow trip,
Donald Trump takes out three adverts in American papers, Washington post,
New York times, uh, criticizing Ronald Reagan, the president at the time,
and lets it be known that he is interested in becoming president of the United
States. Now, you know, the timeline, we don't know what was said.
It's not clear,
but I think what we can say is that Russia has been interested in Mr. Trump for
a long time.
Well, we, we, as you say, we don't know what this implies.
It might might imply that, or, or not at all.
If they don't invite you for nothing. I mean, it's, it's this one.
What, what is what loan that is that they recruited people,
they approached people and even in, in, in your party,
they approached a lot of people. Yes. Uh, and, and did they approach you?
Uh, no people, you knew if my people on you,
even my deputy was a big deputy chairman or definitely leader of the liberal
party he was approached. Yeah.
Um, I mean, what's interesting is during this period,
there's another KGB spy and about 37, 38 years old, uh,
living in provincial East Germany called Vladimir Putin.
And Mr. Putin is trying to do the same thing with,
with students from the local university who he wants to recruit and maybe
central America. And I think really to,
to understand kind of the extraordinary story of 2060 in the American
election, the hacking the shock defeat of Hillary Clinton Putin,
you need to go back to kind of cold war times because it's sort of like,
it's the same methods. It's like cold war too,
but for the age of Facebook and Twitter and everything else,
uh, the is based on, uh.
A dossier or at least big parts of America is,
is by this Christopher Steele. Tell me, who is Christopher Steele?
What are the important stories?
Is someone who worked for British intelligence or [inaudible] for about 20.
Yeah. Cooler than unit. Many times.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. Um, but he, he was, uh, a spy.
He was working undercover in, um, Moscow, um, in 19,
19, 1991.
I mean, this does here is it's, it's been disputed it's,
it's not without fault and even your,
your own newspaper hesitated to, to publish it.
So how come you, you so strongly believe the content of it?
Well, I mean,
I think festival having kind of talked to people close to steal, um,
what I learned was that the sources he used was sources that had been reliable
in the past, who had provided information, for example,
about the war in Ukraine, which had turned out to be accurate.
So they had a good track record. Um, but additionally, we, we,
we kind of know so much more, I mean, the story has moved on. Um,
and we've had the white house saying nothing to see here.
There were no meetings with Russians. Now we know Donald Trump Jr.
Trump's son had secret meetings with Russians, Jared Kushner,
the son-in-law was doing the same thing. Um,
strange foreign policy advisors were running around London,
meeting mysterious professors with Moscow connections. It's I mean, my,
my book is kind of a nonfiction spy thriller because it's the best Shara.
And meanwhile, we have a special prosecutor, Robert Mueller,
who is indicting people, filing criminal charges.
So I think, I mean, I can't speak for prestige, but,
but I think he feels quietly confident that actually has dossier broadly
is right.
Um, even though Mr. Trump himself denies any Russian ties,
uh, the people around him is a lot.
Of things. Um.
But, but, but, but a lot of the people around him is, is obviously,
uh, well collected or it, it, according to your right.
I don't know if you've ever met Rex Tennyson, the secretary of state,
but they have.
You know, what, before he became, he's kind.
Of an oil guy. Yeah. He, he, he knows about oil. Um,
but he has a order of friendship from Vladimir Putin that they kind of push
and gave it to him a few years ago. They kinked glasses. And suddenly,
I don't know. Were you surprised when Tennyson became secretary of state, um,
from nowhere,
but someone who's known and trusted in Moscow and the same with Michael Flynn,
the national security advisor who we now know while he was there's that famous
shot of him, um, at the democratic party convention. Uh,
so the Republican convention where he stands up and says about Hillary Clinton
lock her up, lock her up. Now we know he was actually taking money from Moscow.
Um, and, and one imagines that maybe he will himself be locked up at some point,
we'll have to see him. And yeah.
As I mentioned, there,
there are lots of characters in the book and we can't talk about them all.
But one, I think we should talk about this. That is Mr.
Uh, got a lot of [inaudible].
Yeah. So, so yeah, he's, uh, he's.
He's got a Russian Trump or yeah.
Here's a kind of Russian chump. So, so [inaudible] is, uh,
the he's an oligarch and he was the one who hosted Donald Trump in
2013, invited him to the beauty pageants.
Did the thumbs up with Donald Trump, you know, you know,
that famous sort of thing. What then happened subsequently was, um,
last year during the election campaign, um, uh,
Aguilar has a son who's pop star called MN. Um,
and Evan got in touch with a slightly strange British guy called Rob Goldstone.
Who's a sort of music publicist.
And there were a chain of emails that went to Donald Trump's son saying we have
a Russian lawyer. She wants to come to New York. She wants to meet with you.
And she has information, which from the Russian government,
which will help Donald Trump and hurt Hillary Clinton.
And this was the moment for Donald Trump Jr to say, no, I can't do this.
And instead he sent a famous email, which said, I love it.
I think he took the meeting. I love it. Um, and, and to me, I mean,
my book is called collusion in English. This,
this is kind of textbook collusion. This is isn't like Watergate,
where you have one group of Americans doing bad things to another group of
Americans.
This is one group of Americans requesting assistance from foreign power.
You also have this Carter page character and not a very well-known person.
He's someone that the FBI was watching. They had his phones bugged. Not,
not because they didn't like his suit,
but because he kept on spending time with Russian spies in Manhattan in
2013. And what's funny, I mean, it makes it kind of great chapters.
The Russia spies didn't think very much of him and the way emails intercepted by
the FBI, in which one, spy set of Carter Speight set of Carter page.
I think he's a bit of an idiot. Um, he goes to Moscow more often the night,
but anyway,
this is the matter of advising Trump on diplomacy and
allegedly having secret meetings in Moscow as well.
It's, it's, it's kind of like the plot thickens and thickens and thickens,
and still, it's hard to find the smoking gun.
It's hard to find the hard evidence, isn't it? Well, I mean, you want.
Trump and Putin in.
The sauna. I don't know, but it's like, it's like, it's,
I don't know how are you working with this material,
but it's hard to find that one thing [inaudible].
There are two sides of this plot. There's the kind of Russian side there,
the spying being done by, by Vladimir Putin's team,
which we'll have to wait for a long time before until the,
until the end of the push-in government. Then,
then maybe like with the collapse of the Soviet union, we get some answers.
What's different about that. They've always been trying to do that.
What's different is that that most successful than they used to be.
And also Facebook and Twitter means what you can do is if a country has
problems or difficulties, you can get a whole lot of Russians sitting in St.
Petersburg, pretending to be Americans, British people.
And you can influence public opinion.
W when you, when you talk about the Steele report, uh,
which is very important in your book, uh, you say that,
um, approximately 70,
80% of it is probably true and the rest is unreliable.
Uh, but how, how do you know which 17%?
I think it's quite important. It's a good question. But.
I mean, I think, I think the thing about intelligence is it's not,
it's not black or white, it's kind of gray or offline or CPO,
and you're relying on human sources. A lot of the time, you know,
humans are kind of fluid. We don't always get it right. Or remember correctly,
so there will be errors,
but I think still thinks is broadly correct. And, and what he did,
which was quite smart was he gave all this material to American intelligence and
said, look, I didn't have the resources to verify this,
or prove that it's wrong. You take it over. And, and he kind of lit the fuse.
And that's why from some of last year, the FBI have been investigating.
Parts of this book is, is things that are known. The thing is that,
uh, I mean, you're kind of connecting the dots, uh,
but don't you think it's easy also for Trump supporters to say that again,
liberals here on the fake media, uh, uh,
bad losers, uh, again, they lost, they lost a,
really the Republicans last time. It was also something wrong with the election.
Now it's something wrong with the election. Sure. To kind of see that. I mean,
I can see all that.
On Twitter, but I don't really think it's valid.
And I think what's really important. I mean, this is a time of,
of fake fake news is that we have good method. Uh,
and that we're empirical. We,
we follow the evidence we admit when we're wrong. Um,
we recognize that things can be complicated, but also we try and go for.
The truth. And there are not a million truths that there is, I do,
maybe I'm old fashioned, but there is generally a trends alternative truth, but
I'm kind of protrude. Well, uh, I think this has been very interesting.
And, um, thank you so much, Lou Carney for coming here.
[Inaudible].
We've been talking about, uh, alpha males, uh, um, um,
the Russians. So I have this little clip that I wanna,
I wanna wrap up with and it's with you, you know, uh,
on the Norwegian queen, when, uh,
what is he had sin was in Oslo on a state visits.
This is from the causal bodies had seen somebody in the middle.
[Inaudible].
He was strong. You couldn't see it there on that clip.
He raised us on our feet from our feet when he said that,
when is that strawberry? Did you feel the smell from his mouth?
[inaudible] thank you so much. Take your new 10 things to you.
Hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.